hey everyone
welcome again to one of our live
sessions live q a and discussion session
here of world science you world science
festival your daily equation whatever
you want to call
it a hybrid of all of the above and
as advertised i think some of you saw
that we're going to have a
conversation about dark matter and you
know
second part of the live q a today where
we're going to talk about some
wonderful new research that has been
spearheaded by
a friend of mine and colleague from
yale priya natarajan and we'll be
bringing her in and having a
conversation about some
ideas that at least have the potential
to
upend our understanding about dark
matter and that's
that's really exciting i mean dark
matter as we'll discuss in that
conversation coming up
has been around as an idea for
nearly a hundred years well actually
references to dark matter turns out go
even further back
than a hundred years as it turns out as
we may discuss
but still we don't know what the dark
matter is and in fact we're not even
completely sure that the dark matter
exists
so that'll be part of our upcoming
conversation begin with a little bit of
a little bit of news
you may have heard this exciting and
curious
result that may hint at the existence of
life
on venus the discovery of phosphine in
the atmosphere
venus now look when we think about life
in the solar system the dominant place
that we've long
turned as a potential habitat for
life beyond earth is mars right i mean
you see that in in
so many science fiction episodes
obviously
we've sent rovers to mars in search of
evidence of life venus has always
been looked at as a much more forbidding
place i mean there's a good reason for
that right i mean the temperature is
it's extremely hot so close to the sun
it's got this
atmosphere that holds in the heat over
800 degrees i think
very high pressure but some scientists
are
at least suggesting and i don't think
anybody's going out on a limb and saying
that this
is proof of the existence of life maybe
people are saying that i haven't really
heard that
but the mechanism by which
this particular molecule phosphate can
be produced in the abundance that
appears to be the case
a current living system seems to be
the best explanation that people can
come up with so that's tentative it's
not very indirect
nobody scooped up some surface
material on venus and located
microbes or anything of that sort but
think about how exciting
that would be in fact i'm just curious
for those of you who are
willing to share your thoughts maybe in
the chat or something
do you think that there is life out
there in the cosmos
beyond earth that's big question number
one is your life out there and big
number question number two
is do you think there's life in the
solar system be a venus via
mars be it enceladus europa whatever the
many
places that have been suggested as
possible forms
for life but the third and most
important question i see most of you are
saying yes life exists
yes we think it does obviously for
question one but it's not so obvious for
question number one right i mean it
could be
it could be that life is this incredibly
rare occurrence that even though there's
so many planets
around so many stars in so many galaxies
if you call that number n and the odds
the probability
of the requisite conditions for life
occurring
if that is much much smaller than one
over
n then it's not so obvious but yes i
certainly share your intuition
i would have voted yes on question
number one but here's question number
three at least we have
one no on question number two question
number three
life is one thing intelligent life
a completely different category of life
i mean they're seamlessly connected
but the discoveries would have a
radically different impact i mean
there's just so much of a conversation
you can have with a microbe
it's an interesting and powerful moment
in the history
of scientific discovery to be certain
that life exists on other worlds but
to be able to have communication and to
share
knowledge and and heritage and insights
about the nature of the world to
no longer be having what might be called
a species-wide monologue right we humans
you only talk to ourselves i mean yeah
sometimes to talk to other
like i talk to my dog right so i don't
mean it in in
a very strict literal sense but
the kinds of communication where there's
a back and forth
where the information is truly being
shared as equals we tend to do that
only from human to human and if we could
do that
human to other species on other worlds
wow
right what an amazing moment that would
be and more than that
more than that here's the thing
all life on planet earth shares
basic structures shares the basic way
in which genetic information is stored
in dna it's the same code the same
codons
across effectively all life
the same energy extraction mechanisms
the same energy distribution mechanisms
for the most part i mean there are some
outliers but for the most part
it's all the same it would be
spectacular to come upon
extraterrestrial life
in which it was just completely
different some different
method of storing information
that has been built up over the course
of species or maybe there isn't even an
information storage mechanism maybe it's
completely different i don't know
but that would really be the most
amazing thing so
yes that's exciting news who knows
if it'll stand up to further scrutiny
but that would be a wonderful moment
if the we could really locate life on
another world like venus i should say
you know it's a course i teach
where i have the kids read ray bradbury
short story ray bradbury always was
ahead of the curve and thinking about
the way the world is and might unfold
and i don't know if you've read this
short story i think it's called the
longest day
anybody read that short story ray
bradbury fans out there read the longest
day i think that's what it's called
but it's a story where the
explorers are on venus and they set up
you know colony and they've been there
for a long time so virtually none of
them have a memory of planet earth but
then
an interloper from earth arrives and
joins a a classroom
a school girl joins a classroom and the
sun comes out
once every seven years on venus and
they're all preparing
for this miraculous moment where the
clouds and the rain
the incessant rain will finally clear
away and this one
student this girl who'd come from earth
you know a while back
she remembers what the sun is like and
the other students are all jealous so
they lock her in a closet
for this once in a seven year appearance
of the sun
on venus during this like one hour
respite from the rain and the clouds
it's a it's kind of a wonderful
kind of a wonderful story so you should
you should check that out
all summers in a day yeah yeah yeah
thank you rayna pratt
i had the the title wrong it didn't
sound right to me the longest day
all summer in a day is that story
absolutely
a a hat tip to reign at pratt i
appreciate that
all right so let's um
let's get to some questions if you uh if
you have any
physics math universe
anything at all i seem to have driven
everybody into uh
into a direction that's somewhat off
topic
um all right so um
some weird questions tribe sale does
death hurt
like physically to the dying i presume
it depends on the method by which
death arrives so i don't really have a
whole lot to say
about that uh what else we have here uh
susanth
der garaju can you explain kalabian
manifolds
sure vaguely i can in fact i don't know
maybe we can even bring up a picture of
a clapia manifold while i'm giving this
explanation that's always fun when we
can do that in real time
but collabion manifolds are a
mathematical
description of the extra dimensions
that naturally come from string theory
so many of you are familiar
we've been trying for decades to realize
albert einstein's dream of
unified theory of physics and
many people i'm included in that think
the most promising proposal that has
been developed
in say the last 50 years is this notion
that the fundamental constituents of
matter are not little dots
they're little vibrating filaments and
that small
change this is an amazing thing right
that small change from a dot
like particle to a vibrating string
like particle if the string is small
enough it looks like a dot that little
change
winds up allowing us to put
gravity and quantum mechanics into a
consistent mathematical framework
which has been the stumbling point for a
very long time
in trying to come up with a unified
theory of physics okay good
but here's the thing when you study the
mathematics of string theory
you find kind of amazingly and
remarkably into some
you know this is uh the death toll of
the theory for some it's the most
amazing insight of the theory depends on
your perspective
but the math requires that the universe
have more than three dimensions of space
if string theory is to be right
so we all know about left right back
forth up down it's like the dimensions
around me they're around you we move
through them freely in day-to-day life
those are the familiar dimensions of
space
the math of string theory demands more
than those three dimensions of space so
the natural question that we've
struggled with for a long time
is okay right if this theory has any
chance of succeeding we
better explain where those extra
dimensions of space
are where do they reside and one answer
and look this is what i worked on as a
graduate student
and it's been around for a long time is
this so you got the three dimensions of
space
which are like this grid here but if you
go smaller and smaller and smaller
according to these ideas
you find extra curled up dimensions
right so this animations those
dimensions curled up into the shape of a
circle
that's just for ease of visualization
and the idea is if a microscopic being
is walking around in that environment
they'll know about the big dimensions
that you and i
know about the grid but look the
microscopic bin can also
walk around the curled up dimensions so
small that we don't see them
but the math of string theory doesn't
say that the extra dimensions are these
little circles and now we come to the
question that was asked
this is the kind of shape that the math
of string theory seems to require
for the extra dimensions of space and
these are known as kalabi yao
manifolds there's math behind this these
are complex
killer manifolds a vanishing first churn
class
but you know if math is not your thing
that's fine
this picture is really worth whatever
i've almost said a thousand words
already this picture shows
the shape a possible shape for the extra
dimensions and string theory
and those beautiful curled up components
of space
represent the extra dimensions of the
columbi yao
manifolds now when i was a graduate
student
when i was starting out in the 1980s
when my hair was dark
and the hairline was further down you
know looked like a young man
and thank you for all these who remind
me that i'm aging
as we all are frankly but as a young man
we only
thought the very first paper written on
columbia manifolds only had five
examples i showed you one picture
but there were five known examples of
columbia manifolds and the beauty is
that the math of string theory linked
very precisely the shape of the claudio
manifold with the physics that we would
observe like the mass of particles and
the strengths of particular forces
depending upon the size of the
columbia manifolds and so forth so
the dream was and in some sense still
remains
that if we knew the exact shape of the
curled up component
of the universe we could use that shape
to make
mathematical calculations of physics in
the world that we can
observe so you can't observe the shape
directly it's too small
but the shape casts a shadow into the
realm of physics
that we have access to that was the idea
so as a graduate student i
and a couple friends of mine kelly
kirkland
paul myron our advisor at the time
graham ross
set out to calculate for a given shape
of the extra dimensions the physics that
we might
observe and we picked the most promising
of the known shapes at that time and the
physics that we extracted
wasn't wasn't so distant from what we
observed but it was not really possible
to
do the calculations with enough
precision and to link things up
precisely and
it was awkward it was tricky you had to
jump through hoops
to make these shape this particular
shape i should say compatible with the
physics that we observe
so the thought was well look you know
just go through the rest of the shapes
only four others
at the time and maybe one of those does
a better job and is
bang on accurate in its predictions of
how the world
actually is the problem is over time in
the 90s and 2000s
the number of columbia shapes again i
showed you that one beautiful
purplish blue pinkish picture the number
of shapes has exploded
in terms of people mathematically
discovering different
shapes that meet the equations of string
theory so that now the number of shapes
is not like
five they grew to a thousand into ten
thousand a million
it's exploded to numbers that are
not astronomical would be a paltry
description they're far bigger than
astronomical 10 to the 500
is a number that people kick around and
we have that many shapes obviously
you can't examine them all so some have
viewed this as
the collapse of string theory because
now there's so many different shapes and
you don't know which is the right one
therefore you never can make any precise
predictions is the thought
but others like me say hey it's early in
the game
we've been at this for decades sure but
it's early in the game when you're
talking about a theory that might
address the deepest questions of the
ages right why the universe is the way
it is
right that's the big question of them
all
so many of us just say hey we got to
work harder got to keep
doing our mathematical research you got
to keep trying to find
indirect ways to link up the
unobservable qualities of string theory
to the observable qualities of the world
and that's that's
that's really where we're pressing
onward so that that
perhaps susanth was a longer
answer than you expected but that that's
what a claudia manifilter is the curled
up
extra dimensions of string theory and
that's the role that they play
in our understanding of the world
okay uh andrew hanny sir we are waiting
for a general relativity course
on world science you by you yeah i know
i know i know i feel guilty i sit here
with my
head hung low it's hard to put these
courses together
because i like to do it right and look
one way i could do it
i could i could just do it completely
and formally out of board i don't know
i just feel like i want to do it with
the right visuals i want to do it with
the right interactive demonstrations so
you can get a visceral feel for things
like curved space
and geodesics and
the nature of curve time warp time
so it's just a lot of preparation but i
am thinking that this fall
since i'm not going to be doing any
traveling obviously at least i'm not
going to be doing any traveling this
fall
this may be a time when i can carve out
the necessary time to to get it done
so andrew i'm i'm it's not it's not lost
it's just uh taking a little bit longer
but yes that's
it's on my mind all right neil world
science festival more physics panels
please dr brian keating
yeah i like brian kitty he's great um
uh oh when is the next world science
festival good question neil so
we're gonna start rolling out world
science festival programs
done you know in our look we could have
just knocked out the world science
festival programs by having a collection
of zoom conversations replacing the
stage conversations but
zoom conversations again are just hard
to watch after a while they're kind of
limited
in their visual appeal the content can
be good of course
but you know us we like things to to
really be visually compelling
and and not for bells and whistles sake
but
to really try to communicate the ideas
in
the most interesting and most impactful
way possible so we have spent we took a
breather
when we had to cancel the live 2020
festival
and have been thinking about ways to
bring programs out in
to the digital space that will have the
same kind of
impact although it will be different
obviously but the same kind of impact as
our live programs
in theaters do and i think we've come
upon some pretty good ideas
and we're going to be implementing those
in the coming weeks so
i don't know probably by mid-october
we'll start to release world science
festival programs and i think you're
going to find them
an exciting collection of topics done in
a way
that is visually interesting and
impactful
so so that's that's that's the uh the
status of the world science festival
very much in production
and very much on the verge of being
available
so just hang tight and all that
cool information will become in fact i
think the first program that we're going
to
release if i'm not mistaken is a program
that examines the question does math
reveal reality
right again you guys can chime in on
this you know is math
something that we humans come up with
in order to basically encapsulate the
patterns of the world
that we encounter through observation
and experiment or is math
out there right is math actually out
there
and there are a variety of views on this
my view is more toward the former
that we come up with this stuff but the
conversation
will be with philosopher david albert
philosopher shelly goldstein
who have different views on these ideas
i mean shelley in particular i
understand
believes that consciousness transcends
mathematics so there's something
in the world that is not accessible to
the reach of mathematics and therefore
it's a limitation on math from his
perspective i do not agree with that
but we'll argue it out we also have max
tegmark
many of you know max through his books
and
various uh signs for the public
undertakings that max does
and max has perhaps the most extreme
position
that all math of any stripe
is real it's actually out there so any
math that you find in any textbook
anywhere or any paper however esoteric
that paper might seem max would say
you're actually describing something not
that came from the human mind you're
describing something that's out there in
the world
and i look at that i'm like seriously
but yeah he's serious and he's got
arguments
for this and we'll discuss it and you
know i will respond and you know
philosophers
like david albert if you know him from
our other programs
david albert does not suffer fools right
and he does not take in
you know it'd be kind of interesting to
have a debate between donald trump and
david albert
and that would be that would be a major
mismatch of the minds
maybe it would be too much of a mismatch
sort of like
i don't know if einstein was to
talk to an aunt about general relativity
that's not a bad analogy i hope the
secret service is not going to show up
at my door now
but um yeah so so how did i get there so
my point is that
david and shelly and you know we'll be
really
pressing max to see whether his argument
that all math is real
stands up to to scrutiny uh sylvia jonas
will also be in that program
philosopher of math who has
spectacularly interesting ideas about
where math comes from and the role that
it plays in in human thinking and
society so anyway that's the kind of
stuff that
uh will be coming your way in
the very near future okay
let's see what else we've got here on
the uh the live
chat window here
all right there's just one that i like
but it then i touched my screen there it
is
uh uh raj oven on perez green can the
imagination of human mind be faster than
the speed of light well
so there's no process in the human brain
where
information is communicated from place
to place faster than the speed of light
but um when you talk about speed you
better have a very clear sense
of some kind of entity of some sort
starting at one location ending at
another location
and you are determining the distance
that it traveled divided by the duration
that it took
to complete that journey and if you're
talking about
the human imagination it's not obvious
to me beyond the
physical biological physiological
processes in the brain
i don't really know how to measure a
speed
because i'm not in the context
beyond the actual physical of the
processes i'm not in the context of
something going from here to here a
duration
in in particular duration so
i'm sort of not sure how to answer the
question um
um let's see uh arjun
can we compare one over zero to
singularities and
yes i think that's a very good
comparison so oftentimes when we're
talking about space-time and black holes
the general theory of relativity
the kinds of ideas that emerge we talk
about space-time singularities as
a quality that can infect a solution to
einstein's equations
a black hole right at the center point
the r
equal to zero location the
metric that is the distance
relationships on that space blow up
it's a singularity and when we talk
about that singularity what do we mean
and exactly as you
suspect arjun the one over zero
is a pretty good model of what we're
talking about and when we talk about the
curvature
of say the black hole solution right the
curvature goes like
one over r to a particular power thing
is r to the sixth
i could don't quote me on that but i
think that's the right number which
means is r go to zero
as r goes to zero you do get something
that looks like one divided by zero
so the curvature blows up in exactly the
way that you suggest
so yes that's right alexander
seber brianski
talks about minus 1 12 equaling infinity
and yeah that is a that's a curious it's
a curious fact
that emerges in a lot of different areas
of physics certainly in string theory
it plays a very prominent role and what
alexander is referring to
is if i ask you the question and
many of you are familiar with this from
from youtube or
i've seen it like as a meme on social
media but if i ask you to add up 1 plus
2 plus 3
plus 4 plus 5 to infinity you know
naturally we would say well that must
add up to infinity
right i mean it gets bigger and bigger
and bigger but we in
physics and mathematicians more
generally often find
a way of making sense of certain kinds
of infinite expressions
by fitting them within a larger rubric
of ideas where you don't just look at
one plus two plus three up to infinity
but you look at something similar to
that for instance imagine you look at
one over n to the s
as s goes from one to infinity and
notice when s is minus 1
1 over n is just n so that function is
called the riemann zeta function the
riemann zeta function at -1
is the sum that we were looking at but
the riemann zeta function you can
evaluate it
not for s equals minus one you can
evaluate it for any value
of s and then if you're nearby to minus
one
you can take a limit as the parameter
goes to minus one and define
if you will the zeta function at minus
one to be
the result that you get from that limit
if you excuse me follow that procedure
you find that the zeta function at minus
one does add up to minus the twelfth
and that's the way you can get one plus
two plus three plus four plus five up to
infinity to
sum to minus a twelve so it's kind of a
weird idea
but that's the weirdness of infinity and
it's the way you contain certain
infinite quantities and yeah in string
theory the quantum mechanical vibrations
of a string
winds up including that particular sum
and that minus 1 over 12
it turns out if you multiply that by a
half
it gives you minus 1 over 24. and flip
that upside down
that minus 24 is actually turns into
-26 from using the fact that
you can have dimensions that are
space-like and time-like
and if you take that all in stride
that's where the 26 dimensions of the
bosonic string
comes from it's effectively minus 1 over
12
times a half flip that guy upside down
subtract 2 from it get minus 26
and then the 26 the magnitude of that is
the number of dimensions
and a similar calculation gets you the
10 dimensions
of the super string the super symmetric
version of string theory
so yeah these calculations really do
matter
and maybe sometime i'll do an actual
video explaining that
i i can't imagine that what i described
was clear
unless you've sort of encountered it
before but the bottom line is certain
infinite quantities can be
defined in a way that's completely
rigorous and sensible
and gives them a finite value
okay so what do we got here
on the uh let me look on the list of
questions that we got
on here um so udvash
mainly asked a question that we will
take up
in just a little while which is what is
dark matter
you know is it an object is it a
particle is it energy is it both so yeah
that's a good question
it's dark so we don't see it we believe
it's there by virtue it's gravitational
influence as we will discuss but nobody
can answer that question yet that's the
big question
whoever answers the question what is the
dark matter or
whoever proves that the dark matter
paradigm is wrong and there's a new
explanation and proves that explanation
they they will be getting a trip to
stockholm so
this is a big deal and that's what we
will be talking about
shrindi cabra please explain why string
theory requires more than three
dimensions
gosh i wish i could i mean i know why it
requires more three dimensions of course
but to explain that in
non-technical language has always
stumped me i mean i can give the rough
idea
you know when a string vibrates okay
if the universe say only has two
dimensions of space so that strings
vibrations are only say like on a flat
table top
the number of distinct vibrations of
course is less
than if that string can also vibrate in
a third dimension
which is less than if the string can
also vibrate and a fourth dimension or a
fifth dimension you can't picture that
one but you can get the pattern
that the more dimensions there are the
more distinct
vibrations a string has access to
and it turns out in essence that there's
an equation in string theory that
requires the number of distinct
vibrational patterns of a certain energy
say
to equal a particular value for the
theory to be mathematically consistent
so if you then start to examine a
universe with two dementia like oh no it
doesn't work
math doesn't work there aren't enough
distinct vibrations for a string i say
okay well look
let's go to three dimensions we look
around there are three dimensions
and you have more and you're like oh
darn yeah there are more vibrational
patterns but still not the right number
not enough to satisfy the constraint
of mathematical consistency within
strength you say well okay look let me
be maverick about this let me
think outside the box let me imagine
this is four dimensions of space
yet more vibrational patterns of a
string okay
does that saturate the equations does
that
meet the constraint no it's still not
enough
and you keep on upping the number of
dimensions
increasing the number of vibrational
patterns accessible to a string
until it turns out wonderfully that when
you get to 10 dimensions it all works
the math comes together and that's not
obvious that there'd be any number of
dimensions that would work but it
works that's impressive but then you're
faced with the question that we started
out with
which is if you take this seriously
that the world has to have more
dimensions of space then you have to
explain where those extra dimensions are
and that takes us right back
to the question about columbia manifolds
that we started out with so i can't
explain
why any particular number of dimensions
is singled out
by string theory that that's truly from
the mathematics
but i hope that gives you some semblance
of an intuition
about why more dimensions are
required okay that's a good question
um what else do we have uh
martin topinka from prague can you
explain how a photon can reach infinity
and beyond
in the conformal cyclic universe yeah so
again it's a tough question but
distances in a universe
are measured by something known as a
metric i mentioned it before the general
theory of relativity
and different metrics yield different
notions of distance
and there can be certain metrics that
are such that you can reach the
infinity of space from the standpoint
of say a euclidean observer they'd say
that's infinitely far away but this
other notion of distance
that comes from this conformally scaled
metric
can yield a finite distance so
it's it's it's basically the idea
that infinity in some sense
is in the eye of the metric and it's the
eye of the person who
commits to using a particular metric and
that's why you can have
different notions of which part of the
space are accessible
versus those that are not it's totally
dependent on
the way in which you measure distances
totally dependent on the so-called
metric of general relativity
and certain metrics have
counter-intuitive properties
allowing you to say get to infinity in a
finite
length of time okay
um let's see what else we have what time
is it oh i should uh
i know we have a little time let me just
do a few more questions before we get to
our
dark matter conversation let me see what
kind of uh
cool things you guys are asking about um
um uh
let's see an ankit kumar says there are
56 dimensions according to the vedas
uh yes yes on kit i sort of know that
not that particular number by any means
but i may have mentioned in previous
conversations
that my brother who's a writer
and a filmmaker but he is also a hari
krishna
devotee has been since the 1960s before
many of you were even born
and over the course i mean if you read
my latest book until the end of time i
do mention this
in the nicest of ways but basically over
the decades anytime
sort of we would find something
interesting in strength here physics
and my brother and i who we have sort of
sporadic conversations we
we don't speak every day by any means
and there are long stretches when we
don't have a whole lot of communication
but
it has been interesting it was more in
the old days than more recently that
when we'd come up with some discovery he
would say aha
we know that already it's like in this
or that vedic
text so i was curious about this
and i and i did a little bit of research
i can't say i became
in any way shape or form a vedic scholar
you know but i was just curious
and and the connections that i found
that he was referring to and maybe i
misinterpreted so if you guys want to
correct me
please feel free but the connections
that he was largely finding were
poetic connections metaphorical
connections like when we talk about
the number of dimensions in string view
it's coming from
a rigorous mathematical equation that i
tried to give you a sense
for that equation in words but of course
it's just so far words can take you
but when you see the various
numbers and the various ideas in the
vedic text
they don't emerge from that kind
of a systematic inevitable
chain of thinking as far as i can tell
so so there is a poetic resonance
between some of the ideas of modern
physics and some of the ideas
in sacred text which is which is kind of
cool it's interesting
but that cannot really be taken
as a point of literal contact
between the rigorous science and the
more poetic
metaphorical sacred text descriptions
because look
you know i'm fond of saying if you're
interested
in the magnetic moment of the electron
you can calculate that with quantum
field theory to 10 or 11 or 12 decimal
places
and there's nothing in any sacred text
that i have ever seen
that allows you to take insight about
the external world and push it to that
degree of precision
and and and so that's what i mean by
these connections are
lofty high level poetic metaphorical
whereas the connection that would get us
fired up
i mean really fired up if you go to an
ancient
sacred text and you're like there it is
there's the calculation of that
electron's magnetic moment
and there are all the digits right there
in the sacred text
and here's how the sacred text came to
that number
wow then
everything changes but i i don't suspect
that will ever happen
and that's why these connections are
interesting
and i find them beautiful i find it
beautiful that certain ideas
that modern physics has found
interesting and powerful
some of them have a poetic home in other
ways of thinking about the world
that's cool that's great that's
inspiring
but it's not as though it's the same
and that distinction is important to
keep in mind
so summon name b says why do we need
calculations for it to be true
i'm not saying that you need
calculations for something to be true
i am saying that different
modes of inquiry into the world come
with different yardsticks
for success and different acceptable
modes of analysis and when you're
talking about the scientific
approach to the world the mode of
analysis
is mathematics and careful observation
and experiment and calculation that
attempts to explain the things that we
see
with mathematical precision that
is one arena of human
discovery and exploration
if you're interested in the kinds of
issues
that the world's theological approaches
tend to focus upon then your yardstick
for success is simply different
it's not better it's not worse it's just
different
and for most people a religious
perspective on the world is judged if
that's even the right word to use it's
often not
but is evaluated by
the degree to which it feels right the
degree to which it
enriches life the degree to which it
provides for some
some kind of notion of value or meaning
or a purpose
and in that arena no you don't need to
calculate
anything that's not my point that i was
making before my point making before is
if you try to say these two modes of
inquiry are in some sense the same
they're not i don't think but if you try
to say they're the same
because they both use the word vibration
or they both talk about extra dimensions
if you try to say they're the same
now they're no longer distinct modes of
human inquiry
and if they are meant to be the same you
should investigate that
you should interrogate that suggestion
and to interrogate them being the same
means take the modes of one
and see whether they are relevant to the
other
and calculation is relevant to the
scientific approach and i
the point is making is not relevant to
the theological
approach and that to me is strong
evidence
that they're not the same there can be
poetic resonances but they're not
the same and that's the point that i was
making okay
um aguilat asks is our future
and our present and our past do they all
exist do they all exist simultaneously
and look the bottom line is i'm not sure
nobody really is
but there are arguments that many of us
find convincing
that go really back to einstein
that what one observer considers to be
the present
can be another observer's future and it
can be a different observer's present if
these folks are all moving
relative to each other and so
the subjective nature of the present and
the past and the future
suggests that the sharp demarcation that
we usually make
from the perspective of a single
individual i'm here right now right
that's now the clapping of my hands is
now right sorry if i heard your ears
right
the past future
and sometimes abound this moment but are
not
real or not as real as this moment
that's how it feels to me as an
individual but if
the past is real to somebody else and if
what i call the future
i should have said what i call the past
is real to somebody else and what i call
the future is real to somebody else if
they're moving the right way
then who am i to say that my very
subjective
notion of what's not real holds any more
weight
than anybody else's subjective notion so
one way to deal with that is to say that
everybody's subjective notion is on an
equal footing
and if that's the case then things that
i call the past are real to somebody
else
so they are real things that i call the
future are real to somebody else and
therefore are just as real as what i
consider
to be real which is the present and
that's what einstein basically meant
when he
wrote to the widow of michaeli besso
right that was his friend
that he had innumerable
deeply important profound conversations
over the course of their 50
60 year friendship when michaeli besso
died
einstein wrote to besso's widow
saying that you know he's departed this
world
a little ahead of me but to we convinced
physicists the distinction between past
present
i'm going to say that again because i
got a little getting choked up
really really no it just had a little
catch in my throat
to weak convinced physicists the
distinction between past
present and future is only an illusion
however persistent and and
and that's a again a very poetic way of
saying what i was describing from from
special relativity so in that sense yes
it's possible that the past present and
future
all do exist together
okay so uh zachary asked how did we get
dna that's a good question
zachary a vital one and
if you're interested in a more
fleshed out version of the answer about
to give
again get my book from a library i'm not
a salesperson for my book
you know me i hate that kind of stuff
but this is something that i go into
some detail
in until the end of time because i
wanted
the origin of the universe and the
origin of life and the origin of the
fine structures
that life requires and the origin of
mind and then of course the cessation
of all of those processes i wanted that
to kind of
be put into a coherent framework so that
is something that i discussed but
briefly put
we're all familiar with darwin's
evolution by natural selection but most
of us
learn that i certainly did in a biology
class
in its relationship to the many species
on planet earth so the question darwin
addressed is
how could there be such a broad range of
species and of course the answer he gave
is that over time there can be mutations
in the genetic makeup
of a given individual member of a
species and if that
genetic mutation makes that individual
better adapted to survive in the
environment then that
individual is better or more likely to
produce progeny
who will inherit that mutation and
spread that mutation
widely and over time the accumulation of
many of these mutations
can yield gradual transformations that
ultimately result in distinct species
and if you allow this process to play
out
over you know billions of years time
skills that are very hard for the human
brain to fully process
then starting from some uniform
beginning
you can imagine species branch off
through these accumulated
genetic mutations now that's
evolution by natural selection at the
level of life
but as i emphasize in my book and it's
it's not my idea
but this is well known there can be a
version of evolution by natural
selection not
at the level of living species there can
be a version of that that comes in
at the level of molecules
so in some sense molecules can battle
molecules
in an effort if i anthropomorphize to
gain access to the greatest amount of
raw material in the environment
and so molecules can then mutate
once they learn to replicate this is the
key thing that i should have stressed at
the outset of this answer
once a molecule learns the trick of
replication
it can dominate
the environment if it learns to
replicate better than other molecules
faster than other molecules more stable
than other molecules
so over time mutations in that
replication process can yield ever
better adapted molecules
and over time those molecules and
therefore become ever more complex
and when a molecule not only learns a
trick of replication
but the trick of storing information
then that's an incredibly powerful
molecule
because it can hold on to the
evolutionary lessons of the past
not have to reinvent the wheel so that
sophisticated molecule holds on to
information that can then
sculpt other molecules in the
environment
and now we're talking about a
replicating molecule that holds on to
information
does that ring a bell dna
is an example prime example of that kind
of a molecular structure
so that's the way in which dna could
just have emerged
through the natural blind processes
of physics sculpted by
a version of darwinian evolution right
down at the level
of molecules that's
that's an idea for an answer to that
question again if you want to see that
in more
spell that in more detail you can check
out until the end of time
and um but that that that should give
you a feel for it
all right a few more questions before so
when will priya priya i'm going to bring
prion
in about 10 minutes so arnov
uh yes you're chomping at the bit for
that conversation so
priya should be with us in about five or
ten minutes
um let's see uh
cutie menadi why does light always
travel at the speed of light in a vacuum
it depends on the level of what you're
asking that question in some sense
the vacuum by definition is an arena
that is homogeneous it doesn't change
from place to place to place
and therefore there's nothing in that
environment to influence light's
speed so if light travels at a
particular speed at one
section in one area one region of the
vacuum you would expect
it would travel at the same speed in
another region of the vacuum because
those
regions are in effect physically the
same
there's no distinction between them
because of the homogeneity more
precisely when you look at the equations
of electromagnetism
maxwell's equations you find within
those equations
disturbances to electromagnetic field
travel at a particular speed that
comes out of the math and that speed
is independent of where you are so long
as the environment
is emptied so long as the vacuum so our
observations and our math all converge
on exactly the same idea
subam saaho asks what is the speed of
dark i don't know if you're referring
maybe you saw a youtube
talk that i gave some time ago that when
my son was quite young and i was telling
him bedtime stories about aliens
traveling near the speed of light
he turned to me and asked the question
what is the speed of dark so i don't
know if you're echoing my
five-year-old's cue is not 15. so it was
a long time ago
uh yeah the speed of dark what is it
that's a beautiful idea i was kind of
surprised when when my son asked that
question but
if dark is the absence of light then of
course the speed of dark is the speed of
light
because if light is leaving a region it
leaves that region at the speed of light
so the speed of dark the
increasing domain over which light is
absent
would be equal to the speed of light
which is the speed at which that light
can leave
that region let's see what else we have
uh before we turn to dark matter
um prayage
one of our long time
stalwart attendees at these gatherings
asks a question which is a good one what
is time symmetry what is time symmetry
well it's almost
easier to answer the question what is
time asymmetry and talk about symmetry
in response to that but time symmetry
is generally the idea that one direction
of time
and the other direction of time are in
completely equal footing
within our physical understanding of the
world
and that's a weird idea because if you
think about your life
thinking about the future and thinking
about the past
those are completely different temporal
arenas
the past usually you think of as it's
gone
it's like set in stone it's finished the
future is
open-ended has yet to occur
you can remember the past you generally
don't remember
the future you have the opportunity to
mold the future you don't have the
opportunity to mold or affect the past
so
from an everyday life perspective
there's a big difference
between past and future but you know if
you studied any physics at all
even the most basic equations of physics
show there's no difference between past
and future
past and future in physics basically
amounts to replacing
a variable called t the time variable
replacing it with minus t
that's it positive t going this way
negative t going that way
and the equations that we have are
generally insensitive to that
replacement the equations don't care
whether you're using them to start from
this point in time
and use the equation to predict what
things will be like
or to postdict what things were like in
the past
the equations don't care they don't make
a distinction between those two and yet
we do
so time symmetry is the mathematical
fact that the basic laws of physics as
we understand them
don't seem to show a distinction between
past
and future and that's puzzling and we
have to try to explain
why it is that we as human beings
absolutely do
see that distinction
okay sorry about that i think i'm gonna
i did not bring enough water today so
if there's anybody in earshot of this
plea for more water that would be great
if uh if
water could show up at my door socially
distanced now it's all only my family
here so we don't have to worry about
that
okay um
john olsen asks artificial intelligences
are currently generating realistic
images without having to calculate
movement of every single atom
is it possible that reality is already
simulated by an ai
entity of course yeah that's the
simulation hypothesis that we've spoken
about from
time to time in this gathering and
yeah i mean it's sufficiently powerful
computer ai whatever words you want to
use
could certainly cause us to think that
we are
in a physical world populated by
particles and atoms and molecules when
in reality
all that's happening is we're being
stimulated by the
simulation into thinking that
the world as we typically describe it is
real
when it may not be so there's not a
whole lot you can do
with that simulation hypothesis beyond
you know feeling a bit
you know upended feeling your world is
undercut
you know glancing around and wondering
if the simulator is ever going to make
himself or her himself or themself
visible to us but yeah is it a
possibility
it is i don't go around my daily life
really
worrying that i'm living in a simulation
but i do allow
for that as a as a real possibility and
that's about the best that we can say
about such things
at the moment a robb b do you fear the
singularity
i no i don't fear singularities i hope
that they're kind of far away
that that would be a happy a state of
affairs oh good my son is bringing me
water
yes um so but i don't fear it i i don't
i don't stand in um
tremble at the possibility that there
might be some space-time singular rather
my view is and i think this is a view of
most
scientists singularities are
the big opportunity of say theoretical
physics maybe observational
astronomy too they're the big
opportunity because if we can learn how
to
cure mathematically certain space-time
singularities that may
represent a deep advance in our
understanding and so
you know some of you know i was
fortunate to be involved in some work
a while ago that showed how string
theory can cure
certain kinds of space-time
singularities these are singularities
that would arise if spacer to rip in a
certain
very specific mathematical way and so
that perhaps fearful possibility of
space ripping
we neutered it right we
showed that it could be cured in a way
that doesn't have any
dangerous physical consequences again
within a very specific theory specific
kind of rip
but that's the general way that we
approach singularities
as theorists
okay great um let me do one more
question and then we'll get to our
our dark matter conversation
um okay what do we got how do stars form
good question
gravity basically pulls matter together
until the density and temperature is so
high that nuclear
processes ignite so that's a quick one
there
um um
uh lion king could a black hole be
stabilized after
almost fully evaporating by a hawking
radiation yes this is the uh the idea of
remnants black hole remnants
i don't think most people take that idea
that
seriously these days any longer i mean
some do
it's possible it's definitely out there
but yes it's possible that a black hole
could evaporate get smaller and smaller
and smaller and then it stops
and what's left is a little tiny nugget
and a little nugget might be the end
point of black hole evaporation
absolutely a possibility um do gravitons
exist um somebody asked i don't know
if the traditional way that we think
about quantum mechanics
if that has relevance in a theory of
gravity to make a quantum mechanical
theory
of gravity like string theory then
gravitons
would exist but if there's a different
way
in which gravity and quantum mechanics
talk to each other and it's not that you
quantize gravity but rather
you gravitize quantum
whatever that means if the sort of
gravity is dictating story maybe
gravitons don't exist but i say most
people who work
on quantum gravity would answer the
question yes that that gravitons
do exist um avdut
asked does cause and effect uh is that
invalid in quantum mechanics and no
the cause and effect is alive and well
in quantum mechanics you have to be very
careful
about the causes and the effects you
have to be careful in analyzing
the processes because they're different
from the newtonian classical
processes but if you think about a
quantum mechanical wave function
it evolves in time by a deterministic
equation called the schrodinger equation
and that deterministic evolution takes
how things were in the past
feeds them into the equation and that
then
in that causative manner determines what
that wave function is like in the future
so yeah there's a version of cause and
effect there's a
version of causality that holds
perfectly well
in the quantum mechanical description of
matter
rami als bog asks or says i miss your
daily equation
uh yeah i know it was fun to do that you
know
for a while but to come up with a new
equation
every day and then to sit down and do a
little
discussion of it you know it might sound
like it's trivial
and at some level it is trivial to do
but when you have a lot of trivial
things to
do and i have a lot of other trivial
things that i have to do
you want to realize that your whole life
is being eaten up by
i don't mean trivial sense of you know
trivial that it's not
like useful and important what i mean is
trivia in terms of a time sync
so don't get me wrong that's what i
meant but you have a lot of trivial
things a lot of little time sinks they
add up to a major time sync and you want
to get nothing else done
so that's why i had to sort of uh wind
down and retire the uh the daily
equation but maybe i'll be energized at
some point soon and we'll come back to
it
all right i think with that let me just
take another sip of water here
and uh turn to
the uh the main headline event
if you will of our gathering here today
which is this discussion of dark matter
with uh priya natarajan so
priya is someone i've known for a long
time great physicist she's a professor
at the department of astronomy and
physics at yale
great place he's a theoretical
astrophysicist who's interested in
cosmology
gravitational lensing and black hole
physics and just recently wrote a really
interesting paper
on dark matter that we're going to be
discussing let me bring priya into the
discussion now so if priya can join us i
think priya yes
priya do you see yes you see me as i can
great to see you how are things going
good
um it's actually my sabbatical year
but my wings are clipped so i couldn't
go very far from new haven
so covet clipped or something else yeah
covet clip
yeah yeah and and so uh
you're where are you then i went far
i'm uh in cambridge massachusetts we
went like an hour
or two away something like that yeah are
you at a
university there uh no i was supposed to
spend some time at the black hole
initiative
oh at harvard yeah but you know um
nothing is happening at the moment
remote seminars but no in person
um and i haven't ventured to
um go there i have allergic asthma so
i'm a little nervous
yeah yeah like you know my son
has an autoimmune disorder so like we're
being incredibly careful
because of that so obviously not
anything to mess around with
yeah so um i mean do you get out at all
i mean do you uh
yeah i get out for walks and runs um
and the nice thing is that where i'm
located i'm pretty close to the river
and so i go out for walks and
yeah it's charles river yeah it's not
it's
it's not actually been easy so i
actually live on my own so i'm kind of
used to my own company i'm very social
but you know
yeah um this is hard because this is
sort of you know
not self-imposed exile but you know
hermit hood
uh due to circumstances and i really
miss the thing i
love is i love to cook so i love to have
people over for dinner
and you know it's harder it's harder
you know there was another of course
many physicists have
turned to you know the black death the
plague of the late 1600s
as the model right because newton newton
goes away goes into isolation and
re-emerges with the universal law of
gravity so all of us are like
this is our newton moment right this is
our plague you know where we're gonna
disappear and come but you've actually
now uh i can't say that i've come
forward with anything like that
but you you wrote this great paper it
was just published like a couple days
ago right
right so first le i rolled my eyes big
time for those of you who didn't catch
it
with the newton the plague comment i
mean
the way we sort of valorize this stuff
is just crazy right brian
yeah whatever but yeah this we had a we
had a very exciting paper
uh hey we have to have our we have to
have our myths right
every every tradition has got to have
its mythic heroes and figures
that that you know inspire us to go
forward but yeah i agree
when you examine any of these or not any
but many of these stories you examine a
little more deeply and
uh they're not quite the story that you
were told as a kid
right and also i would personally feel
more comfortable if there were a few
more
like heroines around yeah
there's always that that niggles me that
greatness
greatness doesn't seem to stick to our
kind as easily
yeah well uh hopefully that's changing
yeah hopefully
certainly uh the history of uh of
most sciences is not uh
an emblem is not to be held up as the
model of the way that
that the world should work right
hopefully so coming back to our paper
so it's a paper that's led by massimo
meneghetti one of my collaborators
and um we found something really sort of
surprising
but you know i've been on the trail of
this for a while so
the idea is that you know we see uh
gravitational lensing
sort of the bending of light by some of
the most massive structures in the
universe you see it very clearly for
clusters of galaxies
and the idea is that um you know in our
theoretical framework we know how these
clusters form
and we can now form them in these
simulations in the box
so we can simulate a piece of the
universe and we let it go
and you can form pretty much all the
structures that you see that's how
successful the model is at the moment
so what this allows you to do then is to
directly confront the observational data
what you infer from the data
with your simulated universe so you can
make a mock
observation which mimics your real
observation and then see how do they
tally
um and so um i've been trying to do this
and you know sort of one of their so
first thing you have to do is to you
have to conceptualize
a cluster and observed real object in
the universe
in such a way that this comparison is
amenable that you can actually compare
with simulation so that i sort of wrote
a paper
actually it's one of my first papers in
grad school and i'm going to date myself
i hate to do this but you can go look it
up so i might as well declare
it's 1997 i was young heaven for a
friend you were a graduate student in
1997. but
it was my first year or so okay so okay
so
um and so the idea was that you
conceptual the conceptual model is that
you think of a cluster
as a huge lump amount of dark matter
like a mountain range
but then that there are individual peaks
and the and the reason for that
conception was that
you know most galaxies have their own
individual
halos of dark matter they have their own
glob of dark matter so
explain that i mean there's some folks
who will follow everything that you're
saying but you mind if we even unpack
some of the ingredients as we go along
so you're talking about galaxies and
and dark matter so so like where does
that i mean just give us a little bit of
history of why we even think that there
is dark matter
in in in galaxies right so i think that
there's a pretty rich history for this
right so i think it goes back to the
1930s with fritz zwicky
uh this cantankerous swiss physicist at
uh caltech
what he did is he measured the speeds of
galaxies in a cluster
so a cluster of galaxies oh that's right
that's the iconic picture of him
um so galaxies are held together by the
gravity of the cluster and they're
moving around
and so in the coma cluster which is a
nearby cluster to us he went and
measured the speeds i think of about 12
of them
and he found that they were whizzing
around really fast they were whizzing
around so
fast that it didn't make sense that they
were still held by the gravity
of all the matter that you can see so
you see stars and you see stars in these
galaxies
and he said well there's something funny
going on because there has to be some
missing matter here because there's more
gravity that is holding them in their
grip
galaxies they would fly off otherwise
yeah and so he proposed this
term dunkel materi so dark matter and
that stuck so
he just said well you know you know that
that term actually goes even even
further back we did a little bit
yeah like i think we may even have it i
think poincare
not mistaken uh made reference to uh do
we have that
that that poincare reference
obscure
the translation of that so yeah it's
actually an idea that goes even further
back but you're right i mean i think i
think most people would
would credit zwicky with the first time
and the only footnote that i just want
to put into that story because
his daughter yeah contacted me after one
of my books because i think all of us
have this view
that has been again maybe it's one of
those lore like newton
and you know during the plague coming up
with you know
brilliant ideas she thinks we're being
very unfair to her father
when when when we show that image yeah
yeah
yeah do you know her do you know i don't
know her but i have to say
that i actually admire him you know i
mean i i say cankerous because that
image i knew you were going to pop that
one up
and um no i mean the thing you know
as a first of all right i think zwiki
was the first one who mentioned this
dark matter in the context of a cluster
yeah yeah okay was in the context of the
milky way right
so um you know he had he was brilliant
in terms of the number of ideas he came
up with right
and of course somewhere crazy and out
there but the hit rate was very good and
we forget that i mean this whole idea of
supernovae and what you're seeing when a
supernova goes off
and tying it to the end states of stars
that's remarkable
we wouldn't have found dark energy
without that right i mean so he has made
enormous contributions
right i totally agree that you know we
tend to get sort of fixated because that
images are so powerful
that's why right yeah yeah i mean the
phrase that i remember
that he is all whenever you see zwicky
quoted
they always quote the phrase spherical
bastard
oh my god i can't even never heard that
yeah we're allowed to say those words
yeah yeah
that's actually even uh i think it's one
of the seven allowed words even on any
any network but um the idea here
is that apparently he would say what is
a spherical bastard it's a bastard when
viewed from any angle
so so so so so so these kind of and now
i'm i'm
propagating the exact same
pull back and say this is what it's
typically said but you're right i mean
look i mean
any human beings or rich collection of
events histories quotes sayings
insights and and his insights but i
think
his daughter has a point that you know
as a very important point to make first
is the damage to his actual reputation
the second is as you just pointed out
right by repeating this brian somehow
yeah physicists in our heads we also
start to associate you know what you can
be a
jerk as long as you're brilliant and we
need to break that too
because you don't have to be i mean it
and
then yeah there's no need for that
allowance but
um anyway coming back to the dark matter
so he made um so he made those
measurements and he said okay there's
probably
and he figured there had to be a lot of
dark matter and you know
he wrote this paper it's kind of sunk
without a trace nobody took it seriously
they thought
it's a bit too out there and you i mean
and in astronomy right we've also had a
pretty checkered past and history with
invisible entities like ether
which went away yep so people are like
well you know whatever
this invisible stuff well we'll see but
you know he was relentless that's the
other thing that i do like about him and
so he realized the further
implications that if indeed there was so
much matter
so this was the 30 so einstein's theory
of general relativity was
proven and you know was the star theory
he said aha then it would have to bend
light
because any any glob of matter in the
universe
actually bends the path of light because
in fact
that's how general relativity was first
you know the first major
confirmation was a bending of distant
starlight
by by the sun and you're saying that
any source of gravity doesn't have to be
the sun it could be this dark matter
it acts like a lens light travels
through it
the gravitational pull of that dark
stuff pulls on the light itself
that's right yeah and i think you had a
really beautiful demo that i remember i
think it was on
on youtube right so this whole thing
with space time and
the warping of space-time the potholes
and space-time due to mother
didn't you have this like trampoline or
something yeah yeah we built a version
of the uh
the spandex you know gravity simulator
and we actually set it up in our living
room at home
so it was with my two kids who were much
younger i remember i was gonna say that
you had sort of uh you had a little bit
of child labor
in you i did i did in fact my daughter
was charged with putting the sun
in the middle of the space-time
simulator but she was too little to
reach so i remember in the video i had
to pick her up
and put the sun sun down there in the
middle but yeah that that and it's not
look i mean people often ask me how good
of a
model is that and you know it gives you
the mental toe hold but
the reason why this simulator and the
spandex warp when you put a shot put in
the middle is because
earth's gravity is pulling on the
spandex so of course you're using
earth's gravity
to explain the warp space which is meant
to be gravity so it's kind of chasing
your tail a little bit but
but yeah i mean the basic ideas you're
saying is when matter or energy is in
space it warps the environment that's
einstein's idea
not because something is pulling on it
it's just a fact
of the way gravity works you know and so
i mean i think
as you said one of the places where that
analogy kind of
gets a little fuzzy is the fact that
it's hard for people to understand that
you know
that is the entire universe there's
nothing above it below it because when
we demonstrate we're showing it in air
or whatever
so we are all em embedded in that space
time so light
has no choice but to propagate through
every bump
and yeah in fact korea i'm just
wondering guys can we bring up the three
so here's a 2d version
so you got a distant star that's what
you were referring to and then the
the star light is going on that curved
trajectory near the sun i'm just
wondering can we bring up
the 3d version that we've made of this
where
you see matter moving through a 3d
environment and maybe that can be
brought up at some point as we're
talking
because because i think i have found
that that image really
propels people's understanding because
of the question that you just raised
it's like there's a why under there's
like not exactly
quite above right or above or the side
so it's actually all around
the object that space is being burst so
if we can bring that up if we can grab a
hold of it that'd be great but yeah
going forward light bending so he said
okay you know there is this other
prediction
for the nature of um distortion of space
by matter
and so he said okay let me calculate the
light deflection
if indeed the coma cluster had the kind
of mass that i think it does with the
dark matter he said let me
calculate what the light deflection
would be it is finite
um and it is calculable of course but
it's tiny
and it was beyond the remit of
telescopes at the time remember like a
hundred inch
was like state and that's right
so um oh speaking of which mount wilson
which is in peril right now with the
bobcat fire do you know
i did i fired it looking very going on
really close yeah but um
anyway the um oh no maybe it's not mount
wilson maybe i'm getting it wrong maybe
it's the lick observatory
mount hamilton i think my mother was
wrong
it was hubble but but uh yeah yeah but
yeah so
um anyway the um so you know he then
said that the deflection was too small
but so that was not persuasive either
because you know it was not detectable
so kind of sat around
the idea kind of sat around uh but then
you know completely as is apt to happen
in physics as you know right
we keep rediscovering things that others
have come up with and often don't see
the connection
so aware rubin and kent ford were
looking at a completely different set of
systems so they were looking here
wait what you're right now roughly 70s
okay
so i think following during her thesis
in the late 60s she was trying to
understand
rotation of galaxies like do galaxies
actually rotate
what powers their rotation and then
later she started working
um in washington at carnegie dtm
and saw her with ken ford and ford had
built the spectrograph which allowed a
new kind of measurement which is
a measurement of the speeds of stars
inside a galaxy like a spiral galaxy
from the center out
and i think you might have a visual
phrase i think we do have a visual of
spinning galaxies
uh if we can bring that up that would be
great and the idea of the visual if we
if we get to it
here it is so you so so i guess it was
kent ford's measurements that could give
you the speeds
of the stars in that rotating galaxy
and uh i gather the punch line which we
have in another visual is
that they're moving too fast that's
right yeah and and then so there you so
they should be
being flung outward like bicycle the
water drop is on a bicycle rim as it
spins the water flies off
but they're not being flung outward so i
gather they came to the conclusion
there got to be some dark stuff there
giving right extra gravity
super and yeah i mean you know and um
very rubin
charted what what are called these
rotation curves so that's the speed of
stars as a function
of from the distance of it and so where
when ford looked at them and they looked
really peculiar they looked like they
were it looked like
the stars were being held up on the
outside somehow
right the speed instead of falling there
didn't seem to be kind of an
edge to the galaxy as it were in terms
of gravity
i mean there was an edge in terms of
light you run out of stars but you know
and you know they sat on this paper i
spoke to vera i knew her quite well
she was amazing um and she would tell me
that you know they sat on this she sat
on this for years because the engineers
really two years because they waited to
gather more and more data so they wanted
more and more
convincing data so it was not a you know
it was not a one-hit
wonder for this one peculiar galaxy
right yeah and then
they uh they went ahead and published it
and the implication
was that there was some unseen matter
again
factor of ten but you know i went back
and looked and i even asked her and she
said you know they did not connect the
dots with zwicky because that was a
cluster of galaxies they didn't think it
was the same dark matter at that time
when they were working on it of course
the connections were made soon after
when humans jumped in and this whole
cold dark matter
model was uh proposed and that accounted
for the dark matter
both on the scales of galaxies and
clusters and you know this whole idea
that dark matter is basically smeared
everywhere in the universe
very lightly and then it lumps in
locations and those are the locations
where you preferentially form galaxies
and galaxy clusters and so on
so when we think about a galaxy i think
many of us have a mental image that's
similar to the little animation
that we showed but if you include as you
say
dark matter if you make it visible for
visualization purposes then the edge of
the galaxy is completely different
from what it is so do we have a little
image i think we have an image of a
galaxy together with the the dark matter
component made visible to get a sense of
yeah the kinds of scales that that we're
talking about so if we can bring that up
that would be uh
that would be great um but the idea is
you you if you think about all the stuff
visible matter and dark matter the scale
of the galaxy
can be much much larger than simply the
the
the edge of the spiral arms that's right
absolutely i mean it's almost roughly
speaking it could extend almost ten
times right
and times ten times i think we do have
that visual someplace so maybe
in just a moment um okay so now we're at
a stage
by sometime in the 70s you've taken us
through 30s zwicky
puts forward this idea that's largely
ignored that there may be
some dark stuff out there important for
the understanding the motion of clusters
of galaxies
by the 70s the idea is out there that to
understand the motion of individual
galaxies there's also some dark
component dark stuff and people begin to
think about
those as the same stuff that there is
this dark stuff that's threaded
throughout
everything yeah so then the natural
next question is like what is the dark
stuff made when when do people start
taking that question seriously
1978 onwards sort of theoretically
people started to see how could we uh
explain
observations on these various scales
where this dark matter is showing up and
there was a little more sort of
a deeper understanding of you know star
formation galaxy formation by then
and then the idea was how do you
integrate the formation
and the structuring of the universe that
we see with this unseen component so i
would say that you know the heyday was
kind of 80s
80s and people started to do little
simulations
so make up mock universes to see how
this dark matter would cluster
and so as people started doing you know
so the one of the things
the cool things and uh about this cold
dark matter model
is that you know this model was refined
along the way
as we got more and more observations
right so
um so you know geller and hakra looked
uh
mapped out galaxies in the very nearby
universe and i don't know if there's a
stick
man they found that galaxies are
clustered yeah
and and so they're like okay so that's
something that the theory then has to
explain what what is clustering and
what's going on right
so they were able to then incorporate
the data
as it came along and refine this model
and this model therefore
has you know a storyline of how you
start from some initial conditions
and then you know but that calculation
of
starting from the initial conditions and
getting down to sort of the relic
radiation
that jim peebles did already in the 60s
so the cosmic microwave background and
the fact that the
microwave background that is now
streaming towards us
would inevitably encounter all the
galaxies and everything that's forming
in the universe on route
these things form later in the universe
right and so you know all the pieces
were kind of there already
and then there was this sort of grand
integration
i think sort of i mean it's a way to put
it that every all the pieces came
together and so then we have this theory
but then this theory requires to explain
the observations right the theory
requires that this dark matter
interact only via gravity that it has no
other interaction it's
inert so no no electric
charge no strong nuclear charge no weak
nuclear charge the only way that it
talks to particles in its vicinity
is through gravity right and then the
other and otherwise otherwise we would
have seen it it will like
those are the constraints that that's
the kind of consideration right
and so and the other key thread as i
said right there was this kind of
collection of things that kind of makes
it made sense together so from the
particle physics
end the other thing that came in is that
you know astronomers were able to do an
inventory of how much dark matter you
have
how much do you have to have today the
question then
is that you know on cosmic scales we
cannot single out the behavior of a
single particle of dark matter right
we're looking at aggregates of dark
matter and how they behave
it's cosmic scales whereas particle
physicists
are looking at you know what is this
particle when was it made
and then it became clear that in a
standard model of particle physics which
was also being developed along roughly
the same time
it was clear that it was permitted you
could have
many particles that are produced very
early in the universe
that would give you the right density of
dark matter if they were dark matter so
they're like ah
bingo right we we kind of narrowed it
down to candidates
and so we all became fixated uh
including myself i mean
you know on neutral enos um sort of you
know
as a favored wimps so these sort of
weakly interacting so
you know you permit very weak
interactions if at all
but um massive particles and so
you know then of course there you know
you have to do both things right so
we have all been astrophysically pushing
to look at the collective
behavior of dark matter and particle
physicists have been looking at direct
detection
trying to actually nail down the
particle so you know those two threads
have been going on
and how much how much of this dark stuff
should there be i mean what
how does it compare to the amount of
visible stuff so i mean if you kind of
do
like a pie chart of all the matter in
the universe about 90 percentage
94 95 percent really um
90 percenters should be dark matter so
we're dominated by dark matter dominated
by documentary dominated
now and often when people show pie
charts and i think we do have a pie
chart
we also want them thinking about dark
energy so i know this is not our focus
here today but just so that this pie
chart is clear
can you just tell us what briefly what
the dark energy part of this pie chart
is
right so this this my chart is a full
inventory of everything in the universe
that counts
and so you know the dominant component
in this blue part of this
um diagram is dark energy and this was
um detected
dark energy was detected in 1998
and we believe it is what powers
the accelerating expansion of the
universe
at the moment we believe that it could
really be be a property of space itself
we really don't know what it
is the nature remains an open question
we have some ideas and they're being
actively pursued but
what we know is that it is the dominant
constituent of our
universe and that it does something
quite intriguing compared to
matter so you know when think of matter
and we're going on about gravity which
tends to aggregate it's an attractive
force
whereas this dark energy is sort of this
repulsive thing
because it causes the accelerating
expansion of the universe it's almost
like
space the stretching of space the
there's an
acceleration of that expansion i mean
just like you know when you're driving
you have to accelerate you have to press
the gas pedal and you have to provide
some energy
so the moniker dark energy um you know
and
what it is um we have no clue but but
the main part for our conversation if
you can leave that pie chart back up for
half a second the main the main
relevance for us is
that green wedge is like more than
five times the arc yeah
so so the so you know we pride ourselves
on the depth of our understanding of
how material objects behave in the
universe we have the standard model
particle physics you made reference to
it we can do these very very detailed
precise calculations
but all of that is focused upon that
little orange slice
of the pie chart that you referenced and
that big green
wedge we don't we don't know what that
matter is we don't know what equations
govern it we don't understand precisely
how it talks to the other
wedges in in in the diagram so that's a
great opportunity for us to go forward
and the point that you're making is
there are candidates that people have
put forward
you know my very first paper you spoke
about your early bit my first paper was
on a
on a dark matter candidate you know i'll
update myself now
so that paper was not in the mid 90s but
in the mid 80s
you know so so my first paper is in
mid-80s and it was about a particle that
naturally emerged in certain approaches
to string theory
so so we did the standard analysis to
figure out how much of that particle
would remain today
if it were the dark matter candidate and
as you're saying it's not that hard
to write down models where particles
from the big bang
era would persist until today with the
right abundance to be that green
wedge in the pie chart exactly and for
many of us
and many of these are so-called super
symmetric particles and some in our
audience will recognize that word super
symmetry
but for many of us as theorists way back
in the 80s
when this was sort of first recognized
it was remarkable
that particles that were
coming from theories that had nothing to
do with dark matter exactly
and you stuck them into your
calculations and the amount that would
remain today was exactly on par with
what you needed for dark matter
this was so convincing totally
you know there are many candidates and
maybe we haven't been as
open-minded about um exploring that
space
but um can i share a little secret yeah
we almost
did string theory and was going to work
with wafa cameron waffle okay but
i didn't because i was prepared for it
like i was an undergrad at mit did pure
math
and physics as majors and you know i was
like the prime candidate for that
yeah and work at the time but you know
why i didn't do it
because i did not like the fact that you
could not confront
observations to test it and you had a
good reason you know
rapha was on the previous yesterday
and i think for me actually you know um
i was this like
intense kid right so for me it was like
an existential crisis
i actually uh took a break and i started
a phd in history and philosophy of
science
is that right yeah yeah yeah i know that
the background
so so so so was it so you were
at harvard i should know all the best i
don't know i might not i wasn't like mit
okay okay sds got it
okay but you know it was twofold first
was that i was you know i was
one of those kids who took like a
million courses way ahead did all the
graduate courses i was ready to do
research by the time i graduated
i incidentally i did my undergraduate
thesis uh in particle physics with alan
booth
finite temperature field theory
calculated a mickey mouse diagram
but tiny little nothing major guys no
one should get impressed i mean you know
it was
it was just a little piece of work but
um i found
that i you know as i was at mit right i
was interested in a lot of things always
like super curious and i was always
interested in history of ideas
and and i read kuhn i was quite
influenced by cohn but then i thought
you know
this is not enough um you know this is
how i was like a little kid i was like
you know what this is not enough i think
that he's missing something because he's
not an
active scientist okay i mean the person
if you sit
outside you know and i was like you know
this thing of being an insider and an
outsider
because that was my life right my entire
life i've been a bit of an outsider
and an insider at the same time uh
growing up
uh etc in my sort of history so
that was an idea that appealed to me and
i was like you know what i think
which one should roll with that then
that's what i want to be so i also want
to be
a sort of a philosopher of science and
an active scientist
so and i was young and i said okay i'm
going to do this phd and then i'll
finish it and then i'll go back and do
physics and because i had sort of
reached this impasse i wasn't sure about
what i wanted to do right
because i didn't want to do string
theory that was the automatic next step
and so then i took this detour and of
course i did not finish that phd
my life went in a different direction
and the person who got me there
was another you know i was just i mean
brian i don't know do you think about
this
this i've had such good fortune i'm
so grateful to be able to do what i'm
doing
i mean i kind of reached it you know i
started out being very focused then i
know there's a little bit of detours
when i
got to where i am in terms of always
wanted to be a professor
and a researcher and a scientist and um
i met you know chance meetings right i
met martin schwarzschild he's another
he's one of my greatest heroes
and he is no more and he was um you know
so what i was going to do in history and
philosophy of science
um is in fields like cosmology
where you cannot perform controlled
experiments
and simulations are your experiment how
does that
impact inference how can you validate a
theory
and test it with a simulation i mean
it's all related to the work that i'm
covering
now so these are questions obviously
they're top of mind for
folks who have gone into string theory
because oftentimes it's not even a
simulation for us it's just
analytic mathematical equations and
internal consistency as opposed to
comparison with observations so
these issues are are very close to us
but let me just ask i mean do you feel
like an outsider still
in some ways yes right i mean i um
obviously intellectually i'm very much
you know uh
in um in sort of the
an insider but you know as a woman
woman of color um and as a person
there are many ways in which i feel that
i
uh stand out uh and in um so also in the
scientific style
um that i work on my own unlike most
astrophysicists who are now you know
theorists are sort of joined into big
collaborations of thousands of people as
a pet theorist
i've not done that uh and the reason i
haven't done that
um is sort of a choice because i want to
take creative risks and you can do that
you know in those sort of collaborations
it's a lot of consensus building about
science and the scientific questions
and how you tackle them and i like to
have this freedom of just
running with an idea myself so i work
with smaller groups of people
so um i think in that sense i feel a
little bit like an outsider
and you know and and brian you must do
right those of us who have interests
that go
well beyond we don't fit the stereotype
of what this kind of uh you know intense
scientist is supposed to be like
i mean i i i know that we are
we have a lot of things in common uh you
know we love to write
we like to engage with the written word
as well as equations
um and we think that science is
a creative pursuit like many others
we're interested in art in history this
that and so you know i think there's an
image of who is supposed to be a serious
intellectual scientist
and i think there are people who
probably would count uh
me a little bit on the outside that you
know i think people want to box me
i think and when i was young i found
that really difficult because i so
wanted to be belong you know i want to
be one of the big boys right and then i
actually realized now that you know
not being able to box you i in any way
put you on the inside or the outside or
whatever is actually a very powerful
position
yeah yeah no totally i i completely
agree i mean
you know there was a time when it was a
lot of soul-searching for me and perhaps
for you too
should i spend my time solely doing
research when i'll write the most papers
and and have the greatest impact in
science or
should i split my time between doing the
research and doing
other things like writing books or doing
tv shows or doing this kind of
conversation that we're having here
right now
and you know the thought occurred to me
that you know you write a really good
paper in physics
and it influences a couple a handful of
hundred people
typically you know whereas you do
something
you write a really good book or do a
really good television show you
can influence millions of people and and
so
the influence is different and the
impact is different but there's value to
each and i've
basically gotten to a point in my life
perhaps similar to yours where
i just do whatever feels right at a
given moment as opposed to try to fit
myself within a particular rubric
you know the usual rubric as you say is
you do your calculations you do your
research you do it from the beginning
you become a graduate student until you
leave the field
possibly in a box that's right and and
and my view there's just more to life
than that and so if you can flesh it out
in interesting ways that have impact you
know although
all the better all the more power
powered teams i
just find that my mind is stimulated
like i
i find that um of course you know you
are incredibly
powerful in your reach and how
amazing clarity you have in explanation
um
i find that uh for myself it's just that
you know when
i'm grappling with sort of ideas and
histories of ideas and so on
it actually makes my scientific work
much better yeah
yeah it pushes me
and you know it is hard i am trying to
do like
both with uh sort of equal intensity
it's difficult and i think i can pull it
off
i have to confess i pull it off because
a i am a workaholic okay you know what
whatever
i am a workaholic and i don't happen to
have young kids or i have to care for or
whatever right so
i don't have those kinds of uh
responsibilities that bind you and it's
all time
everything is time but um anyway so i
think you know the
this kind of obsession with simulation
so i went met martin schwarzschild and
he said what are you doing this for
do you want to do simulations i said no
no i want to work with ideas
so then he said oh i know the person you
need to go work with i don't know why
you're doing all these humanities you
know that you can always do that later
priya you know
just learn how to write i said oh yeah
that was a hard thing to learn
because i had to take all these graduate
humanities courses and then i went to
cambridge england and then my life
changed and then it was theoretical
astrophysics and it was
you know dark matter black holes and you
know and then
idea was i would go back and finish i'm
abd i thought i'd go back and finish the
phd but
you know i realized that as you said
that it's a better outlet to actually
write a book
and you know and to and to express what
i uh
have been learning and digesting and
thinking so you still i do have any
thoughts of of completing the other
degree or uh
well i do have a master's i mean i got
him you know i went i was there for
three and a half years so
you know um and i actually quit actually
one of the frustrations i was also
frustrated with that
was because this was the time again
dating us uh when the sociologists of
science were really kind of you know it
was the high point for them
so i was tired of having discussions
with some of my brilliant
classmates you know is this stable made
of atoms
are are atoms just a good way to
represent whatever this table might be
made of and i'm like no guys
i've seen a diffraction pattern and i
think yes there is a conceptual model
but you know there's reality
and i was like you know what i um i am
very open-minded about critiques of
science uh
and sociologists critiques of science
and i think that uh scientists
needed that um but i'm not for that
extreme strong program but you know that
science
there's no content to science everything
is context i'm not there
yeah neither nobody i i think it's not a
sensible position it's not supported um
but anyway that was the reason i wanted
to quit i was ready to leave as well and
get back to science
so i'd love to return i want to return a
moment to your dark matter but
just since we've gone down this
interesting trajectory i mean
you know there may be young women
watching this or will watch it on
youtube
do you have any advice you know for for
young
women who are in a position that you may
have been in 20 years ago
who want to be scientists what what
words of advice would you give them
well you know i mean i um i don't have
any great sagely words of advice
luckily things have changed a lot and
there's a lot more
um lot many more opportunities to pursue
science and different kinds of science
now
i think you know when i look back um i
find that the thing
it's a it's a it's perseverance
persisting
you know it's a it's a quality that we
don't give as much
credit to in terms of uh in science
but i i mean you know you you will face
a lot of obstacles everybody is going to
because i mean there are going to be
intellectual obstacles and other
obstacles intellectual because that's
part of science
constantly trying to push your mind to
learn more
so you have to love that frustration of
pushing yourself more
right now and i think you have to
persist and not give up
too easily because you can give up
intellectually or you can give up
because of circumstances if you don't
feel welcome somewhere
or i think those other situations the
other
circumstances are changing um and i wish
they were changing faster
but um i would say you know it's just
very glib to say
follow your passion but it is true you
have to kind of be stubborn
and you kind of have to stick with it
wouldn't you say right i mean it's
it's advice to any young person well i i
mean i give
similar advice i i think the advice that
you gave is particularly
useful for you as a role model to to
other
girls and women who would want to follow
in this kind of trajectory
the more general advice that i typically
give
emerges from the fact that i have and
you probably have this too i have a lot
of young
science students come to me
and they want to immediately jump to the
forefront
like i want to work on string theory or
i want to work on you know because
i'm like whoa have you taken classical
exactly
have you taken the electromagnet have
you taken citizens so i really emphasize
to kids
like watch programs like this and read
books and see television programs we
read new scientists or scientific
american whatever
to get excited about what's happening at
the forefront but you've got
to focus in on the basics no and get
your foundations absolutely
the same thing you have a lot of high
school kids writing to me i was like oh
you know i love black holes let me do
research could you give me a project
yeah i'm like you know what uh research
is there for you it's very exciting as
you say follow it
but why don't you just master the
foundations yeah because that's what you
really need if you
master the foundations then you know any
research field you can get in
and and you can make a contribution and
you can make original contribution there
is
i have no doubt because i think i
personally believe that you know every
kid
no matter what color what gender every
kid has a very unique gift to bring
to whatever they do be it science be it
the arts be it
any profession the question the big
journey and adventure of life is to find
what it is
that is a good match to what you
can creatively do your creative juices
match the problem or the the place where
you can contribute
and all of us who are so fortunate to
have made that connection
early in your in our lives but it's
never too late
yeah and i agree that that is the big
that is the big
question and uh i agree i do feel
incredibly fortunate in exactly the way
that you described that i sort of found
something that fired me up that i was
good enough at to make a contribution in
and uh yeah i mean i sit here and often
like i mean i'm in the middle of writing
a book like writing my last book i said
i can't believe that i'm given the
freedom to do this
by the way i loved your last book all
right i love it
yeah i love the ambition of it because i
really like these sort of
um ideas grand synthesis of ideas yeah
i think it's very stimulating and it's
um and it takes
time before you can um write right so
yeah i'm called up
also writing yeah but you know i am
getting distracted by my work yeah
you're wonderful last book that was
actually out just a couple of years ago
four years ago that time flies yeah so
you're in the middle of writing uh again
you know
i mean you know i'm on this trail of
understanding
sort of radical scientific ideas so that
trail i'm still on that same trail
kind of a new direction um but anyway
coming back so you know
the obsession with simulations and the
eye testing simulations was kind of
always there for me it was kind of a
long thread
and so you know i came i finished my phd
i was very very lucky you had a great
advisor did work
really it was you know it was a time of
great personal turmoil
and i i mentioned this only because you
know we always say that you know
great stuff happens when you're really
troubled sadly for me that was true
that it was a moment of enormous
personal difficulties in my life
and when i moved to england and i poured
myself into my work
and you know you could tell that i gave
it everything
and and it became me and it was kind of
hard because i became a super workaholic
at that point
yeah yeah and but um then i was very
fortunate i
barely did a postdoc i became a fellow
of trinity college and then i got the
job at yale
so once i came to yale i continued this
thread
of lensing and lensing was new at that
time so the observational data was just
coming in
and the reason is you needed hubble
space telescope
kind of resolution to start seeing it
and once you have it you see lensing
everywhere i mean and in clusters of
galaxies if you go and look an image
of taken bubble space telescope
beautiful right by eye
you can pick out all the distorted
shapes even by eye
you can see it right just because the
galaxies are normally you know
elliptical
or spiral and they just have this sort
of weird bend to them when you look at
the imagery because as we're saying
before
the light is bent by the gravitational
pull of the matter
especially so you have this cluster of
galaxies so you know i've honed in on
the system of cluster of galaxies
because they
are the largest repositories of dark
matter so any lensing effect that you
find would be most
dramatic and so you know you have all
these distant galaxies you have this
cluster that is in between
us and this whole population of galaxies
in the universe
and you end up seeing very mangled
images of the background
and the idea so you know as part of the
process you know because i was early in
on this game
develop the methodology to look
at mangled shapes and
infer back out instead not just look at
those and analyze them
but use that to figure out how much dark
matter is in the lens
got it got it and the reason you can do
that you know it sounds odd like how
could you really do that well you know
galaxies are born with a distribution of
native shapes they have birth
shapes however clusters are extremely
rare
in the universe so they're very i mean
you know so when you look at the night
sky
most often you are not looking through a
cluster
they are very rare so the rest of the
night sky
is not as distorted which means you have
the you have the baseline
you know what the baseline is and you
know modulo that baseline you're able to
figure out
so in this work we've just been
following so you know what you can do
now is that as the data is getting
better and better you can compare
with the theoretical conception of the
cluster as this mountain ranges with
peaks
going to a simulation look at let's look
so you showed it before but people
probably uh
don't have it in mind so you were able
literally from the observations
of these mangled distorted galaxies you
were able to in essence come up with a
map
yes of the distribution of dark matter
in in that region and and can we bring
an and the peaks and valleys that you're
referring to is
very dense dark matter here less dense
dark matter here and so forth throughout
throughout the region so if we can bring
up a picture
is this an example of what you're right
this is from our work in uh 2017
where so this is a cluster this is the
mass distribution in a cluster and i
just want to show that this purple stuff
is actually a mound it's above the
baseline in the universe
okay already heaped and then on top of
that heap
you have all these little peaks and
these peaks correspond to the location
of cluster galaxy so you know galaxy
cluster has about a thousand ish
galaxies
that are held together and each of these
peaks is associated with a cluster
galaxy you know so that was the original
conceptual model i told you right
and that has stood its stead and that is
sort of verified as
a useful way to conceptualize the
distribution of dark matter in a cluster
and remember we talked about this is
where the connection back to where
ruben and the individual galaxies come
right so we saw that individual galaxies
have their own extended dark matter
and when they fall into a cluster some
of the dark matter may be lost in the
fall
but they retain their own clumps so each
one has its own blob and gloop of dark
matter and those are those peaks
are heaped so dark matter is heaped in
those peaks as well as an
overall kind of mound which is a larger
scale distribution
and now you're able to compare this if i
understand to the simulations that
you're
talking about and see whether the
physics as we understand it that's
embodied in that simulation
is agreeing with the actual observations
exactly
through this indirect means is that your
most recent paper is that
what you do in that paper that's exactly
and and you know we already so what you
can do you can go into a simulation you
can look into a region where you have a
cluster
and count up these peaks you can count
up the peaks you can look at their
locations roughly and
and you and you what you do is you pick
clusters in the simulation box in your
universe
that would produce the right amount of
lensing so they have the same amount of
mass
and they are apt to give you and you do
this statistically right so you take as
many clusters in a box you can make many
of them
so that was the original challenge over
the years when i was trying to do it
these objects are rare so your simulated
box has to be quite large
to have enough of them so that you can
actually do a statistical analysis right
so you need a lot of computer power to
have a box at large and stuff
and that became available like the best
kind of state-of-the-art simulation
where you could do this became available
in 2016.
and that was the illustrious simulation
so this
image this dark matter map it's it's the
most detailed map still
spatially of a cluster of the dark
matter distribution so
what we did is we we found that
intriguingly
the number of clumps on average matched
very well
but there was something amiss in terms
of the detailed distribution of the
clubs
so there was a hint that there was a bit
of mismatch
a very small hint and you know and i
really wanted to follow through and that
is where this new paper
comes in so one of the things that you
need to pin down this model
to get this you know the heights of
these peaks the heights of these peaks
are basically the amount of matter that
is associated dark matter with an
individual cluster galaxy
so then you have to play the vera ruben
trick to go and measure
the stars so that these clusters are so
far away
that we have not measured like she did
you know the speeds
all the way from the center to the
outward but we can make a central
measurement
a key measurement of just the inner part
how fast of the star is moving
and that's what in this paper we were
able to do with this wonderful
spectrograph on vlt the
telescope operated by the europeans so
we were able to get spectra so
detailed accurate measurements first
to determine the membership without
ambiguity that this cluster galaxy is
actually sitting in the cluster it's not
in front of us it's not behind us right
so that's a crucial source of
uncertainty in all the modeling before
you can make any grand claims you have
to do like the basic sort of checking
out
and then we made measurements of the
speeds of stars
in the centers of galaxies and we made
sure that our they were incorporated
into our mass model
which means we have the best
observationally constrained at the
moment
distribution of dark matter so then you
can start doing some precision tests
and because the hubble data is so deep
what you can do is instead of just
looking at the large scale lensing
you can now zoom in and see if around
any of these individual clumps
do any of these individual galaxies in
turn
double split the light themselves
so which means they produce smaller
scale events yeah and you can see them
in the insets right in this uh
in this figure but we found that because
the data is so good now right so this is
what is wonderful about the convergence
like the data is good
and the simulations are very
sophisticated so it's you know it's a
it's a good
time to do a detailed comparison of the
kind that we were doing
so what we found is that these small
scale clumps with these individual peaks
shown in the previous map they are doing
their own little lensing on top of the
big lens
so it's almost like you know because you
know this lensing as you know right we
have often makes analogy with just the
usual glass
optics lenses that we are all familiar
with it's almost like you have this one
big smooth lens and on top of that you
have a lot of
lenses yeah and so what we did is we
said okay
let us look at a quantity let's device a
metric
that can quantify the capacity of a
cluster
to do a lot of small scale lensing
and so we defined this metric uh it's
called galaxy galaxy strong lensing
probability
and you can calculate that for real
clusters in the universe and it we
didn't do it just for one
it was a full sample of 11. and the data
that we used i told you with the speeds
um you know the extremely well
calibrated were three clusters
it's very expensive in terms of
telescope time
but you know in general it kind of
ratified our modeling
and it showed so we were able so we use
11 and then we calculated this
quantity which tells you the capacity of
small-scale clumps to do strong lensing
split images not just
mildly stretch them but actually split
them like the cluster does
and like individual galaxies sitting in
the field also do so that is known that
it does happen
individual galaxies can have enough mass
to do the splitting themselves
so we were very surprised that we found
such events in the clusters
but then we went into and with this
metric we calculated the probability
and we did the same calculation in the
simulations and we found a mismatch
of an order of magnitude i see and
that is huge because and then big
mismatch yeah yeah and
so you know simulations do not have
cluster galaxies uh concentrated enough
to have the capacity to produce as many
of these strong
lensing events on small scales so what
does that tell us
well we could be missing an ingredient
in the um simulations of clusters
clusters are really complicated they're
very dynamical and you know there are
it could be as simple as like you don't
think it's like a bug in the code or
anything as simple as that because the
agreement
with the other qualities is just too
close right and we tested it with three
different sets of simulations
done by different groups with you know
different uh um
methods and you know different
approaches even
computationally if you give us a sense
these simulations like
can you describe in sort of lines of
code i mean how big
are the computer programs necessary
they're just huge i mean
yeah i mean and you know they're modular
so i mean some of them could
be close to you know several hundred
thousand uh lines of code
because because these contain recipes
for the formation of
galaxies you know for black hole
activity
black hole do it some of these things we
kind of have to put in by hand it's well
motivated but you know we put in by hand
so if you add in all the pieces of
physics that have to be put in
it's a lot of code and like how much how
much how much general relativity
is in in this code is is it mocked up in
a
newtonian way or or is it like full
general relativity
well it is patched right so the scales
on which general relativity is relevant
and important
it is part you know so the expanding
universe background is very much
they it's they're quite realistic and
then of course in the regions of the
universe that have decoupled from the uh
rest of the universe like an actual
galaxy
there it's all newtonian pretty much
right so i think they patch
in uh they're self-consistent these are
amazing bits of code and it's an
incredible
achievement to have kind of um codes
that we have
and we have a multiplicity of them now
and and they you know there
there's all these adaptive meshes where
you can refine and zoom in
without losing the larger scale you know
you don't make the kind of trade-offs
i mean of course the number of particles
is finite and you could do better and so
on but it's pretty spectacular with the
billions of particles right
yeah so what we found was that this
mismatch means that maybe there's a
physical process
um that is missing in the simulations
when you say missing in the simulation
you mean that perhaps we've just been
missing
right i mean this could be pointing to
something that we're just unaware of and
that's why it's not in the simulation
right a physical process that we have
assumed is not important or doesn't
occur
or we haven't even understood as you say
occurs in clusters
right now what about for dark matter
though is it
is this a potential challenge to the
whole dark matter paradigm
right so the other possibility is that
there's something fundamental about the
nature of dark matter we have missed
so we have with this cold dark matter
model
quickly tell us why cold i don't think
we ever talked about the core
oh it's because these particles move
extremely sluggishly
compared to the speed of light so yeah
good so going from there sorry
just one not at all um and you know so
these we have attributed only gravity to
them which means they condense and
aggregate
only via gravity we there's no other
force there's no other interaction that
can squeeze them further
and so you know they have a peculiar
equation of state right sort of in
chemistry we know from
gases like we know what the equation of
state like boyle's law
so the pressure the volume and the
temperature are related so if you
squeeze
if you squeeze gas with a piston you
increase the pressure and so on
but cold dark matter is really peculiar
because the equation of state is p
equals zero it's pressure-less which
means it doesn't collide with itself
because you know pressure you have only
because molecules collide with
themselves or with a container or
whatever
but since these particles are
collision-less they don't collide with
each other
you can't condense them you can't you
know they can't you you don't lose
energy and dissipate and become more
compact you can't concentrate dark
matter
to the levels that you can concentrate
ordinary atoms
which is why the centers of galaxies are
so replete with stars right they are
very high density of stars
because gas can collapse
and it gets denser and denser because it
has pressure and the density goes up and
i think you mentioned
uh in one of the questions i was
listening in earlier somebody was asking
you about star formation
so because this pressure and you can
squeeze the density and you eventually
ignite
nuclear uh fusion um
you can't do that for dark matter
because you can't squeeze it in enough
there's no force that
permits you to squeeze it in so it's
just gravity and it's kind of this loose
aggregation
so this suggests that in the centers of
cluster galaxies
somehow the matter distribution is much
more concentrated
so you have ordinary matter of course
there and you have dark matter right
and so it obviously we could have been
we could be missing
maybe there is you know i'm not going to
speculate too widely right
but it could be that dark matter either
interacts with itself
and squeezes somehow uh itself to get
more concentrated or it interacts with
ordinary atoms or baryons in a way
that allows it to dissipate and squeeze
and get more concentrated basically
and you know and i think what is
intriguing though about
both of these options um is that they're
both
really significant implications for the
field and our thinking about dark matter
if you're missing you know simulations
have been the backbone of this field
because we can't do controlled
experiments remember so this is our
that's our experimental lab and if
you're missing something
there i think it behooves us to pay
attention to figure out what it is right
so i mean have there been any uh
theoretical papers
perhaps written before or written since
probably too soon although people work
very quickly
that offer a a theoretical answer
that meets the mismatch between the two
well i mean
i haven't and there's been nothing so
first of all we kept our results under
wraps like
we are supposed to and so we didn't
really leak it to anyone so no one
people are just our colleagues are just
learning about it
yeah you know the hint that i found in
our 2017 paper that's out there that's
been out there
i think people have been looking for
looking at possibilities there's some
suggestions
and in this paper in science right you
have all the supplementary material
there's 14 pages of validity tests in
which we actually kind of look at all
the possibilities
many of the obvious possibilities you
know maybe the simulation isn't good
enough maybe you missed something
um you know maybe you are
the black hole activity is moving out
too much matter from the centers
because that's what we want the black
holes to do to explain other things that
we see
so you know we turned off we ran
simulations in which we turned off black
hole activity completely yes
there you know we can get rid of a
little bit of um the discrepancy
but you know the thing is it's annoying
gap it's like you know an order of
magnitude
is quite large factors of two we can see
and there aren't factors of five
different factors of two that would all
combine in the right way i mean we just
couldn't find anything which is why
the paper is open-ended well that's
great yeah the other
question about the nature of dark matter
is you know problems on small scales
with the cold dark matter and people
have suggested solutions but you know
those problems go in the opposite
direction
you need galaxies at the centers of
galaxies to be
not so concentrated you need them to be
smoothed out
but those were problems that were
detected not in a cluster environment
but for individual galaxies galaxies
like the milky way and not sitting in
the middle of this kind of you know
happening cluster yeah well look you
know um
although it may be a myth the with
newton and the plague
uh we'd like to story maybe this really
will upend the dark matter paradigm in
some significant way and uh
you will have used your time away
from ordinary world in a very productive
way if indeed that's the impact of this
work so it's a beautiful paper
thank you so much i think it's going to
have a lot of impact i think i think a
lot of theorists are going
to try to rise to the challenge and come
up with
ideas that bridge the gap between the
simulations and the observations and i
think it's going to be a
very exciting time so thank you so much
for spending some time
going over you know all sorts of ideas i
want to quickly mention
for the audience that priya has a world
science u
course that is going to be released i
think in the next
week or two or three something of that
sort i don't have the exact date in
front of me but
you guys should keep your eyes out from
that it's
again a wonderful exploration of these
kinds of ideas
and uh we look forward to uh whatever
forthcoming book
uh emerged from uh your uh
you know radical studies about how
science is done
and uh it's been a pleasure speaking
with you so
thank you so much you speak again yeah i
miss
our i miss coming to the world science
festival um
i come even if i'm not speaking it's a
train ride away for me
so i really miss all the activities
hopefully we can all
uh do stuff in person before yeah i
appreciate that and again you know we
we the festival's not gonna stop we put
it on hiatus to figure out the best way
to do it digitally as i mentioned
earlier in the conversation
to the uh the youtube audience and so no
doubt we'll have you in some world
science festival programs going forward
whether it's live
or digital but for the moment of course
it will be digital but yes i certainly
look forward to uh
our paths crossing in a literal as
opposed to a virtual sense right and
yeah i want to say thank you to you for
all that you do brian
uh it's very important work thank you
very much and thanks for joining
inspirational yeah appreciate that thank
you all right so thank you very much and
we're going to just do a little bit more
q a
before we wrap up i'm not going to go
quite as long as i sometimes
do for reasons that i will not
articulate explicitly just to say that i
have to get back in shape for sitting
still for
three hours when one is drinking a lot
of
water okay a couple questions before we
wrap up here um which is a great
conversation i hope you guys enjoyed
that
discussion of dark matter and the uh
various ways in which scientists try to
analyze its presence
indirectly dark you don't see it but you
analyze its presence through its effect
on the things that you can see
and through the way that it lenses as
pre was described you can map it out
and then you can compare that to the way
the dark matter should be distributed
based on your understanding of what it
might be and the ways in which it
interacts and
that mismatch is uh a powerful clue
perhaps to either what dark matter is or
to the fundamental laws of the processes
that
it engages in okay so what else do we
have here i mean we'll do a question two
before we
wrap up here so jim blonde says dark
matter will go the way of the ether and
it may
it may well be the case that just as in
an earlier
generation the notion of an ether was
hypothesized to make
sense of observations observations
having to do with light
we have hypothesized some more invisible
stuff
to make sense of our observations today
of motions of galaxies and most of the
stars and galaxies and you're right
that may be a stop gap measure which
goes away with a deeper understanding of
the laws of physics so i'm not
in any way saying that that isn't how
things will turn out we just
do not know at the moment um
alex asks oh daegu asked brian what
would be a bigger discovery life on
venus
or or dark matter you know i i'm not
one for creating hierarchies that much
in discoveries i don't really people
often say who's the better scientist was
it newton or was it einstein i'm like
you know at that level it's so
spectacularly high that it
it doesn't matter the hierarchy doesn't
matter
but um you know in some sense the
discovery of dark matter would confirm
something that we've long suspected to
be true so i think many people
if dark matter turns out to be a weakly
interacting massive particle
wimp has pre-described it you know if
that turns out to be the case i think
everybody would be wow that's that's
spectacular
but in the end we'd nod our head and
having confirmed something that we
thought would be the case you know life
on venus is not something that
people have really spent a lot of time
developing and thinking about so
its immediate impact on the scientific
community
might be larger but again the point is
any of those discoveries would just be
spectacular off scale once in a
generation kind of insight
so it's just exciting across the board
without any need to order the various
discoveries
um alfred asked could you do a narration
from the big bang to quantum physics a
narration
like sort of a show and and yeah i
should say you know
uh i mentioned my book before until the
end of time
again library i'm not selling it but i
mention it
in response to alfred's question because
we're also in the early stages of
developing a television
adaptation of that and that would go
from the big bang to quantum physics and
beyond so there may be something of that
sort in the not
too distant future all right final final
question before i um have to um
to uh leave um
um rajev asks why is light
massless and and light didn't have to be
massless our understanding of its
dynamics of its physics how it behaves
points in the direction of it being
massless and our observations
of it which are quite precise by this
point in the game
suggest strongly that it is massless but
you know
if it turned out that um way down in the
future with
ever greater precision somehow we're
able to measure
light and its property it has a little
little tiny mass so small that today's
detectors would be unable to be
sensitive to it
we would find a way to accommodate it
and it would change
fundamentally our understanding of the
basic equations
and the basic properties of light as a
transmitter of the electromagnetic force
but we would be able to accommodate it
so it's just to say that light doesn't
have to be masses in the sense that it
would be logically inconsistent
to ever imagine light as a massive
particle
i mean the transmitter of the weak
interactions the w and z bosons are
these are massive particles
and they are transmitting a force much
the same way that the photon does
so it doesn't have to be logically
speaking massless but everything that we
know
points to it being massless all right
with that i'm gonna
i'm gonna wrap it up for today again
thanks for
joining us for our first q a hour and
then this discussion in the second hour
with with priya on dark matter and we
will
announce i'm not exactly sure if we're
going to stick at this time going
forward
but we're always open to hearing
suggestions for a more convenient time
and we try to take that into account
scheduling these events
if you want to make suggestions for who
you'd like perhaps to join in for part
of these discussions happy to hear those
suggestions as well
and with that said keep a look out for
priya's world science u course take a
look at my own world science u course on
special relativity that's sort of a
12 hour version and there's the two hour
version that are out there in the world
space time and einstein
and so until we meet again uh take care
i've enjoyed the time we spent
today together bye